imagine waking up one day and seeing
yourself being sold online
to multiple men multiple
times and the worst thing is you don't
know what what's worse that could happen
and your mind immediately goes there
that look
this is just my picture that they've
screenshotted and used for this purpose
what else do they have on me what else
can they do to me
[Music]
i kind of shrugged it off but then i i
saw that there's more of it and there
are many women on that list
and i remember that time i actually fell
violently like i started puking
on my way through the assignment and it
was just bad it took a bad toll on me i
got one whatsapp message from a
journalist friend
who said that my name features in the in
in a horrific list a list which is up on
one of the apps on a platform called
github
and this app is called
basically they have put names of
hundreds of girls and women muslim women
um and uh they are auctioning us online
we are up for sale and there are mobbed
pictures and morphed videos and
basically they're projecting us as maids
who will be auctioned in no time
[Music]
the harassment
and the communal targeting
is
has become you know almost
like we're supposed to internalize it
has has is becoming like a way of life
and that is very unnerving and very
unsettling
[Music]
so when they see
uh muslim women being on social media
talking about things just existing in
fact that's unacceptable to them and
they're saying okay look we are sending
out a message to you but also to the
entire muslim community that
you know stay in your lane right like
these things the minute they keep
happening over and over again they
become normalized this is the third time
this is happening in the last one and
one one and a half years the third time
and that is absolutely unacceptable
[Music]